[Music]
on TV on radio
and on your smartphone this is talk
[Music]
TV tonado appear going censored in New
York City Israel raids Gaza in tanks as
it edges ever closer to a deadly ground
Invasion Hamas says 7,000 Palestinians
are now dead I'll talk live to naftali
Bennett the former Israeli Prime
Minister also tonight raised by
terrorist mosab Hassan yusf is the son
of one of the co-founders of Hamas
tonight he issues a chilling warning to
the Palestinian
people and at least 18 people are feared
dead many more wounded another mass
shooting in America will'll debate
whether there can ever be an end to
these kind of mass shooting
[Music]
tragedies live from New York this is pi
Morgan
uncensored good evening from New York
and welcome to PE Morgan uncensored
Israeli Defense Forces have raided Gaza
in tanks edging another step closer to
the invasion they promised will come and
come hard already Hamas says that 7,000
Palestinians have been killed in Israeli
strike since the terror attacks of
October the 7th prime minister Netanyahu
says that many terrorists are dead and
this is just the beginning but the
devastating reality is that countless
more innocent people will be dying and
it's only the beginning of that too 224
Israelis are still held captive by Hamas
Gaza is on the brink of a humanitarian
catastrophe now Fury and grief is
Rippling across the entire region
president erdogan of Turkey today
accused the west of turning a Blind Eye
of Muslim blood after launching the
shocking defense of
Hamas Hamas is not a terrorist
organization but a group of liberators
and mujahidin fighting to protect their
land and their
citizens no it is a terrorist
organization that's indisputable
especially now well the stakes here
couldn't be higher I support Israel's
mission to eradicate Hamas they're a
bloodthirsty medieval bunch of
terrorists who've done irreparable harm
to the Palestinian cause but Israel's
yet to explain how it can take out Hamas
without killing many more innocent
people in the process it's yet to
explain what it will do with Gaza if it
somehow succeeds in getting rid of Hass
if anything much of Gaza left at all is
yet to explain how it can defend itself
without breeding a whole new generation
of hatred and resentment which now
threaten stability across the Middle
East there have been ugly scenes on the
streets of major West cities including
London and New York with vient
anti-Semitism and prass protests
meanwhile many Muslims and supporters of
Palestine are Furious of what they see
as a vicious double standard it's hard
to see how this gets any better before
it gets a hell of a lot worse and here
in America yet more tragedy overnight at
least 18 people are dead after a mass
shooter with a history of mental health
problems when on the Rampage in Maine
when that news broke last night it
struck me there are some uncomfortable
parallels with a debate about Israel
I looked at the photograph of the
shooter in open-mouth revulsion I saw a
killer prowling Suburban streets with a
weapon of more of War but I was reminded
that many Americans look at the same
photograph and see a weapon that could
potentially save their fam's lives in a
country that's a washed with guns one
image one gut-wrenching tragedy two
intract intractable positions and as
with Israel the gun debate isn't my
fight I'm just an outsider looking on in
horror and as with Israel I don't have
all the answers I just know that
somebody needs to find some and find
them
fast well tonight I'm joined now by the
former prime minister of Israel naal
Bennett Mr Bennett thank you very much
indeed for joining me um I want to start
by playing a clip of Benjamin Netanyahu
uh obviously your successor as prime
minister this is what he said about what
he sees is the mission involving
Hamas sorry deal be done that doesn't
involve sitting across a table with
Hamas I've met several times with Hamas
leadership and I think they are willing
to accept Israel my apologies uh Mr
Bennett we played the wrong clip there I
think have we got the right
clip yeah we're just going to play the
right one my apologies Hamas militants
are
doomed above the Earth
underground within Gaza and outside of
Gaza we already eliminated thousands of
uh terrorists and this is but the
beginning at the same time we're getting
prepared for the ground Invasion I will
not tell you how when and how
much Mr Ben first question I guess do
you think he was right to say that
you've eliminated thousands of
terrorists uh Hamas is claiming and we
have to take their figures at their word
and I'm not sure how credible they are
but they're claiming 7,000 Palestinians
have died since October the 7th but we
don't know how many of those are
terrorists and how many are completely
innocent civilians do
we well Israel and the idea of always
Target uh the Kamas terrorists uh yes
sometimes the Kamas terrorists use
civilians as human Shields but I
wouldn't uh trust hamas's uh statement
as we saw just a few days ago uh it was
Islamic Jihad who shot a rocket at a g
in Hospital Hamas claimed it was Israel
the whole world uh echoed that for about
24 hours until it turned out that it's a
total lie and it indeed was Islamic
Jihad so I I wouldn't assign too much
weight to their words especially given
that they're a group of uh rapists and
murderers so why would you trust them no
no I I completely concur that you don't
have to take their figures uh just
because they say these are the figures
but what is clear is a lot of civilians
innocent people as well as I presume
some terrorists have been killed so far
by the Israeli uh response with the air
strikes it's clear also that a major
ground Invasion will massively increase
the number of innocent people who die
and I've asked this question to a lot of
guests in the last three weeks I'll ask
it to you what is a proportionate
response because people are already
saying look 1500 people in Israel were
killed it was barbaric it was evil it
was an act of horrible terrorism but if
7,000 people or several thousand
whatever the correct number is already
been killed in Palestine what is the
number which becomes unpalatable even
for people on the Israeli
side so it's not about uh
proportionality to what happened it's
about preventing what will happen what
we've realized is that we have a Isis
State on our border uh people who will
rape murder dismember bodies kill babies
from point blank so it's not about what
happened it's about the future how do we
uh protect and defend Israel there's
only one way total eradication of Kamas
so when you think about proportionality
it's not about the the numbers it's
about how we get them out but I will say
uh Piers that IDF is very focused on uh
preventing unnecessary deaths that's why
we went out of our way according to
international law and we allowed roughly
800,000 gazans from northern Gaza to
evacuate away from Harm's Way so in the
the theater of operations as has been
already made public is going to be
primarily Northern Gaza and we're
allowing ample time giving precaution
warning you know bending over backwards
to reduce the amount of uh civilian
casualties but what happens to those
800,000 garans if all their homes are
complete Ely destroyed what do they come
back to do they come back if they can't
come back where do they go where do they
live look uh Israel's responsibility is
not to provide housing and a high
quality of lives to an enemy State I
don't recall America or Britain uh
asking those questions about Japan or
Germany during World War to uh our goal
is to minimize civilian casualties but
our main goal is to eradicate is Hamas
that's the main goal now we W in the
southern part which is sort of the Safe
Haven area or we've created Safe Haven
corridors we are allowing anyone to
provide water food and Medicine in the
safe haven corridors so we're about
protecting lives the fact that uh
thousands of uh gazen and Kamas citizens
and uh uh terrorists went in and raped
and killed Israelis yes it has
meaningful consequences that they
brought about themselves I also want to
point out uh that contrary to what
people think there were also many gazin
civilians that entered uh Israel and
just horrible things for example we we
have uh evidence in in videos of uh CI
gazin civilians coming out and saying
that girl we don't want to murder keep
her for rape I want to rape her that one
we murder that one we take hostage so
it's you know the the notion that Hamas
is totally divorced from um the massive
public support of gazin is untrue having
said that we still are going out of our
way to allow uh the citizens away from
Harm's
Way Queen Ria of Jordan uh was very
vocal this week gave a very impassioned
interview and which she accused Israel
of being an apartheid regime uh said
that there's always a distinction in the
west between Israel's right to
self-defense against any right of
Palestinians to selfdefense which is
always categorized as terrorism she said
that whilst what happened October the
7th was savagely barbaric why is that
terminology never used about what Israel
does to Palestinians what was your
reaction to Queen Ria and that
interview well she totally lied and said
simply wrong and reprehensible things
let's let's undo the unpack this she
talks about a part hiide let's talk
about a part hiide there's about a
million and a half Israeli Arabs they
vote in the elections they have one
ballot like I do there's uh uh over a
dozen Arab members of knesset uh we have
Arab Supreme Court judges so we have
Arabs even serving uh some of them in
the military they enjoy full equal
rights in Israel so saying that Israel
is an part heide State simply has
nothing to do with the fact if she wants
to bring some facts to substantiate her
her lies I challenge her bring me facts
that show that Israel is a paride a b
regarding the uh barbarism and savagery
of uh of Hamas Israel never in our 75
year history did anything near what they
did I I want to explain I I today spoke
to a family the Zach family the parents
and the younger brother were were
murdered they were waiting in the
shelter and the the the sister uh uh
Hadar was not there she told me that the
the dad was holding the shelter handle
so the terrorist can't come in what the
terrorist did they burnt the whole house
and suffocated the mom the dad and Young
Brother Sagi his only comfort was they
found Sagi and his mom hugged on the bed
in the shelter as they were
suffocating this is something that no no
no decent person would ever do so shame
on Queen reah shame on her uh and and
the fact that she can say these blatant
lies is simply
deplorable many people uh in Israel 80%
I think in the latest poll believe that
Benjamin Netanyahu should express some
personal responsibility and apology for
the catastrophic failure of security and
defense on October the 7th you have now
said publicly that you feel responsible
for what happened on your watch as prime
minister which may have contributed to
the failings why has Benjamin Netanyahu
not done the same and should
he You' need to ask him uh I don't want
to stand here and criticize the Israel's
prime minister I may have a profound uh
differences and and the thoughts but I
have a habit where I don't criticize uh
Israeli leader during war and certainly
not in international
press but there's no doubt it was a
catastrophic failure and he is the guy
at the Top If you had been prime
minister which you were several years
ago and this had happened on your watch
would you have
resigned I don't want to go into into
that because again it's a domestic
Israeli politics uh I have my set of uh
ethics and standards that I adhere to
for all my life
you have to uh send all these questions
to prime minister netanel we've got a
war to
win both uh President Biden and indeed
Queen Ria and many others are saying
that the only way this gets resolved is
politically with people getting round a
table I think it's pretty clear that
cannot be done as long as Hamas are in
charge of Gaza and certainly uh depends
if there's any Hamas left at this the
end of this ground Invasion anyway um
you said in June 23d
the following uh you said I have a
friend who's got shrapnel in his rear
end and he's been told it could be
removed surgically but it would leave
him disabled so he decided to live with
it there are situations where insisting
on Perfection can lead to more trouble
than it's worth and your quote which
became known as shrapnel in the butt
quickly became widely known as your view
of the Palestinian problem and you've
always been resolutely opposed to a
two-state solution do you think that
kind of rhetoric helps and do you not
think now that the only way out of this
actually is to have a two-state
solution I uh totally disagree I think
uh what people don't realize and I think
that you gave me a good opportunity now
appears to emphasize we provided the
Palestinians with a fullblown
Palestinian state in Gaza in 2005 since
I think most your viewers do not know
this Israel pulled out of Gaza pulled
out all its soldiers pulled out all the
Israelis living there 8,000 Israelis
handed the keys to the Palestinian
Authority there was no Siege no blockade
nothing and they had the opportunity to
turn their state into Singapore and from
the very first moment Piers they began
shooting Rockets firing rockets at our
towns since then we've had tens of
thousands of rockets from the very Gaza
that we evacuated did so they had the
full opportunity and they blew it we did
the same thing in Judean Samaria aka the
West Bank in during Osa Accords we
handed we pulled out of of all the major
cities ramala nais kevron Janine gave
the keys to the uh PA and what we got
from year 2000 and on was a barrage of
suicide attacks in Tel Aviv and in K and
Jerusalem so what I've learned
I'm a very simple guy I look at the
facts and by the way all Israelis the
overwhelming majority of Israelis agree
every time we hand land over to them
give them the responsibility and the
keys they turn it into a terror base
against us so how stupid can we be to
try this failed approach for the fourth
and fifth time we need a different
approach and I don't want to govern the
Palestinians I have no desire most
Israelis do do not desire to govern them
so make no mistake but certainly we
cannot allow them to have any Arms any
army any Terror organization and the
first and foremost thing that prevents
peace is having Hamas so there's no way
to even imagine uh peace as long as
Hamas exists on uh this
territory naali Bennett thank you very
much indeed for your time I appreciate
it thank you very much okay coming up
the man who was raised by Hamas
terrorists masab Hassan yusf who the son
of one of his Founders he then renounced
toas and his family he joins me with a
powerful message for the Palestinian
people that's uncensored next live from
New
[Music]
York we're here good morning everybody
hope you're well thanks for joining us
you're watching the independent
Republican Mike gra right here on talk
TV welcome to Friday night with Nadine
here on prime time we like to speak to
the business people behind big moments
good evening I'm Piers Morgan uncensored
in New York City very impressive well
played I'm three days into the job what
have I done wrong and your face just
stared out at me me and you conquer time
who wins you do you know what I love
about tour today we do it all sunak
sella scon
[Music]
are you actually speech writing for this
you soon I'm so rich frankly uh I'm
going to take the side of booze gits
against these pomp you mean you're not
going to support mayor Jose L
not stop panding to the nimes to the
naysayers and The National Society for
the preservation of the habitat of the
Lesser spotted M the problem lies in the
bureaucrat it's almost highly paid
Consultants don't really know what
they're
doing the first thing they teach you in
weather school is never confus dog
walkers with Doggers Twitter you sons of
can you please reinstate my account
thank you there's a threat that you'd be
worried about so are you saying that
you're being overwhelmed that you're
inundated we are really working hard for
you and we're just asking patients to be
patient with
us the one thing label would be
terrified of if Boris Johnson zoomed
back into full Focus Boris Johnson uh
isn't what he was most of them seem to
have given up welcome to the talk it's
really great to be back my little
dog fit as a butcher's dog there you go
he's fit as a butcher's dog all right
but but he's now middle CL here test the
knock on effect is far larger than just
CO2 I nearly have empathy when I'm
speaking to them I know know you're
probably going to boot me after show
after got to say I'm not I'm not a
Swifty critics i' say me included got
former PMS all over the joint saying
things the last few days we have indeed
yeah great first show you having fun oh
a ton of fun King PE and King Cube I
think there's only room for one king man
you know what I'm
[Music]
saying welcome back to P sensored live
from New York City masab Hassan YF knows
Hamas better than anybody else he's
spent many years in Israeli jails
because of his links to the terror group
and those links could hardly be more
direct his father shik Hassan YF was one
of hamas's founding leaders well masab
ultimately FL on Hamas while in Israeli
custody spied for Israel his
intelligence is said to prevented
suicide bombings and other attacks he's
now an American citizen after claiming
Asylum and a converted Christian but
he's watching events in Gaza with barely
concealed Fury from his now undisclosed
uh location and he has a chilling
warning for Palestinians in this
interview we recorded earlier and I'm
joined Now by mosab Hassan yusf mossab
great to see you um it's an
extraordinary story yours uh you were
the eldest son of a man who was one of
the co-founders of Hamas and indeed for
your early formative years you worked
alongside your your father so you got a
great insight into Hamas tell me this
from the start what were the intended
plans for Hamas when it was founded when
it started when it developed what was
the plan you know since its
establishment uh Hamas uh
has one goal in mind which is
annihilating the state of Israel like
the best let's say compromise that they
could do is having a truce for 15 years
a ceas fire for 15 years as maximum you
know but with no guarantee how they will
act after it's
absurd ER it's not a secret that Hamas
wants to destroy the state of Israel
they cannot accept Israel or AC accept
uh Israel's right to exist what was the
point uh that you decided to get out of
there to to flee this world this
environment you've been brought up in
you know I I have I have many reasons
since I was a child I asked my father
many questions about Hamas delusions
about their brutality about their abuse
of power and always he justified you
know their uh position then I was
imprisoned with Hamas I spent about 27
months in Israeli prisons where Hamas
was torturing their own members our own
people within Israeli prisons they
killed actually and tortured hundreds of
prisoners uh and this is when I start
asking myself the question what if Hamas
become the ruler at some point what will
they do to our people and uh many years
later Hamas became the ruler of
Gaza and I wasn't surprised by their
brutality when you heard what happened
on October the 7th what was your feeling
about that look as I told you I'm not
surprised by Hamas brutality but I was
surprised by the scale of their attack
you know not to this degree wiping out
entire communities you know messing with
the nuclear power the most powerful
country in the region a country with a
uh trauma great Trauma from the past
with a a memory of a holocaust and all
the Nazis did in the past Century you
they opened uh the Gates of Hell on the
Palestinian people this is how
irresponsible this group people are you
know that they are willing to actually
sacrifice many Palestinian children the
entire Palestinian people and use them
as a fuel to just achieve their
ideological uh agenda they religious
agendas they are careless they don't
care for the human life we have to
separate between what so-called
Palestinian cause and Hamas cause Hamas
cause is a sick one it's coming from the
pit of Hell you know and they need to be
removed uh from Power this is my message
as an ex Hamas member as a son of one of
Hamas Founders that enough of this if we
don't stop them now the next war is
going to be deadlier and only God knows
what will happen next if Hamas is not
finished as soon as possible M how many
regular Palestinians particularly in
Gaza do you think sympathize with Hamas
or indeed fully support them you know
once Hamas is removed from power we are
going to witness people celebrating in
Gaza I guarantee you that the people of
Gaza are oppressed for so long and they
had to endure Siege they had to endure
violence many
wars uh uh for the sake of Hamas uh uh
lust for power and for Hamas political
ambition when this comes to an end I
promise you that the Palestinian people
first of all will thank Israel for what
they did
second the uh idea of Anala the Jews and
the state of Israel will be dropped
forever you know because Hamas is the
you can say the last
experiment uh of adapting violence
trying to annihilate and destroy the
state of Israel this didn't work for
yaser Arafat it took him 40 years to
realize this and Hamas has been trying
for 35 years to destroy Israel finally I
hope that they will come to this
understanding that Israel is going
nowhere if they insist on annihilating
Israel and of course if Iran keeps on
insisting uh on this goal this means the
destruction of the entire region this is
the only uncertain outcome of this
because Israel is going nowhere how do
we get to peace from here you know this
time I'm afraid that war is the only way
to peace uh because if Hamas is not
removed from Power uh then they will uh
build more military they will build uh
longer uh range missiles and the next
attack the next war is going to be
deadlier the use of force is the last
resort you can find this in every
culture and
unfortunately now Hamas left Israel and
the Free World as well with no choice
uh but to fight them and put an end for
their
violence uh many civilians are dying I
understand this their blood is on the
hands of Hamas and Hamas only you see
it's interesting you say that because a
lot of pro Palestinians who I've had on
the show in the last two weeks don't
accept that argument they say the blood
of the civilians in Gaza is exclusively
on the hands of Israel and that Israel's
waged uh a repressive occupation for
many decades um there's been a prison
camp for gazans for a long long time and
that that has created the environment
through which a terror group like Hamas
can Thrive and indeed win an election as
they did in
2005 do you buy into any of that I mean
do you think that Israel has overreacted
already to what happened to them their
argument is what is proportion when you
have a terror attack like that on your
people look since my
childhood uh and I am hearing the
stories from Pro Palestine and from
those who are using what so-call the
Palestinian
cause they care the least for the
Palestinian children and their future
you know I I am the legit legitimate
representative of the Palestinian
children the child Within Me speaks I
don't want somebody coming from London
or somebody coming from the other side
of the world to tell me what is the
struggle of the Palestinian children the
Palestinian children the Palestinian
Society has been hijacked by this
criminals and anybody who takes side
their side is participating in their
crime this is my answer to those people
and for the civilian casualties Etc you
know first of all Hamas is using and
it's very clearly it's a fact that Hamas
used civilians as human shs it's a fact
then it's a fact that Israel called and
warn civilians to evacuate buildings
before they strike them but in the
meantime Hamas put roadblocks to stop
civilians from evacuating to Safe zones
Hamas single misfire killed hundreds of
refugees taking shelter at a hospital
and they blamed Israel what are we
talking about here Israel is a Dem y
Israel is accountable Israel is not
thirsty for the Palestinian blood in the
meantime Israel is capable of wiping out
Arab Capitals in seconds why Israel does
not attempt to abuse its power but why
when the Arabs have just a little bit of
power couple of missiles they misuse
Power by lunching them at civilians and
kill them in their living rooms we have
a fundamental problem and we need to
stop blaming Israel we invited this upon
our heads and the rest of the world if
they don't know the reality on the
ground it's better than is mosab your
passion uh and your anger is very
palpable here and certainly very
different to most of the pro Palestinian
voices I've had and you I sense the
Palestinian plight of its people is very
much in your heart do you still have
contact with with any of your family
this is irrelevant right now I don't
have any contact with my family and I
don't care anymore more you know enough
Bloodshed and enough involvement from
people who don't care they just uh
warriors on keyboard you know and
they're just
storming uh world capitals saying free
Palestine free Palestine they don't know
what the hell Palestine is I am
Palestine and I say it's enough of Hamas
it's enough of the corrupt leaderships
that they are killing our people
misleading them to hell is enough of
that we don't want Palestinian State I
don't want Palestinian State Palestinian
children need education they need
security they need life this is what
they need they don't need another
corrupt Arab regime is it possible to
get rid of Hamas in the way that Israel
is currently trying to do through uh air
strike bombardments and and it is
planned now an imminent ground invasion
is that the best way to do it is there a
danger of radicalizing a lot more young
Palestinians to the Hamas cause in the
process listen to
this we are going to remove Hamas from
Power remember my words okay and Hamas
did not only bring the wrath of Israel
Over Gaza Hamas brought the wrath of God
we are going to remove them from power
and we are going to persecute their
leaders and we are going to bring them
bring them to justice and the world will
witness their punishment and everyone
who who take their side today in this
state of confusion thinking that this is
a joke I tell those people that you're
going to regret taking the side of Hamas
you are going to take the to regret
taking the side of those criminals who
are uh killing uh the Palestinian people
mosab you were born in rala that's your
home do you dream of going home one day
is that something you still aspire to do
I prefer not to ask to answer this
question I understand mosab thank you
very much indeed for joining me um it's
it's extraordinary to hear your story
and it's uh a remarkable pitch that you
make to the people of Palestine and it's
one that um they will hear and will see
their reaction but I appreciate you
joining me thank you very much thank
you we'll get that reaction after the
break now kiswani and Emily Austin are
both back after the very heated debate
on Tuesday and Louise mench and I will
be trying to keep that interview under
some kind of control that's uncensored
next live
[Music]
from
[Applause]
[Music]
this is talk
TV
welcome back to p on sensor live from
New York City I'm joined Now by my P the
founder of the communitybased
Palestinian Le organization within our
lifetime Nadine kwani former
conservative MP Louise mench and the
broadcaster Emily Austin all right uh
let's try and keep things civilized sure
we um Nadine I guess for you two things
um you were born in Jordan you just told
me off fair you're an American citizen
but very much a Palestinian in your
heart obviously and your blood what did
you make first of all before I get to
what um what masab youf was saying what
did you make of Queen rani's comments as
the queen of Jordan about all this you
know I believe that all Arab leaders um
can take a stronger stance in support of
Palestinian Liberation particularly
considering that you know the entire the
the citizens of Jordan most jordanians
support Palestine if anything actually
most um people who live in Jordan are
Palestinian descendants that have been
ethnically cleansed from their land and
ended up as refugees in Jordan just like
my family did um and so I believe that
you know uh Jordan and and all these
Arab countries should stand
unequivocally with the people of
Palestine even stronger now and masab
youf there I mean it's an extraordinary
interview with a guy whose father was a
founder of of Hamas he's absolutely
clear that he believes you got to get
rid of Hamas and then there can be peace
and there can be what people want there
do you agree with him I believe if you
want want to stop Palestinian resistance
you're going to have to kill every
single Palestinian because regardless of
whether what if you want to stop Hamas
terrorism I believe any form of
resistance Palestinians take is going to
be called terrorism but terrorism isn't
resistance if you actually commit an act
of Terror how can Palestinians defend
themselves in a way that isn't
considered terrorism well I'll give you
the difference which was argued actually
Gary Kasparov the chess uh Legend today
articulated what he saw was a difference
on October the 7th hundreds of terrorist
invade a country Israel and they
brutally rape assault murder uh set on
fire innocent civilians that is by any
yard stick an act of appalling terrorism
Israel responds with what they say are
targeted air strikes at places they
believe Hamas are hiding in Gaza that's
disputable I get that but that's what
they say they are qualitatively
different the death toll may not be
different but the intention of what is
going on is different and that's exactly
what happened in deia in 1948 where
people were raped where villages were
pillaged on fire bombed at tantura where
Palestinians had to dig their own Graves
before they were shot into it may I
England started just to finish this
point England orchestrated this genocide
so I'm actually happy that you know both
of you are here um we I'm resisted you
know but uh you know but you're you have
a lot of reach there um so we resisted
when there was the British occupation
and we will continue to resist any
occupation that exists in Palestine all
right let me bringing Emily I just want
to ask you a question so last we left it
you did refuse to uh condemn Hamas
murdering Israelis on October 7th and it
seems as if nothing has changed but I
couldn't help but to think do you Al do
you condemn 911 that's such a ridiculous
is an interrogation ofor it's it's a
simple questionus no it's of course you
stop deflecting question
ridiculous what is the difference
between Israel's 911 I'm not here to is
she the interviewer or are you she's
raising I think I think the point she's
making and yes I'm wrong is if you
condemn that why won't you condemn what
Happ that was Israel's 911 I'm not here
to answer her questions because are we
did this last week I will now ask what
Emily just ask it's actually a valid
question is 911 if you're happy to
publicly condemn 911 why you not happy
to condemn Israel as 911 in fact it was
a lot worse
statistically 11 is palestine's 24/7
that's completely compl bring bring in
Louise here I found it really shocking I
have to say that your organization
within our lifetime said that it was an
act of resistance on October the 7th I
mean that is the most unislim thing I've
ever heard in my life tying the hands of
little children behind them covering
them in petrol and then burning them
alive please tell me what is resistance
about such inhumane torture of kids
since you wanted to bring up Islam in
Islam we believe that the Bloodshed of
any innocent person is equal to killing
all of humanity um and this is something
that you know we believe unfortunately
Palestinians are put in a situation
where they're in an open air prison what
we were celebrating that day is them
breaking out of that open air prison I
don't understand how the world expect
one of the reasons is one of the reasons
why you're not so Keen to condemn what
Hamas did on October the 7th because
you're fearful of publicly doing that
are all Palestinians fearful of speaking
out against Hamas actually because
there's a very reason very good reason
to be fearful no there's no reason to be
fearful my life is not if anything you
know living in New York City my whole
life there are many Zionist institutions
including the universities that I
attended um and campaigns against me for
being pro Palestinian including putting
my face um on trucks to drive around
Midtown in Time Square for two weeks um
just this summer calling me a Jihadi so
that's what I'm it's not because you're
Pro Palestine it's because you're Pro
murder there's a big difference we are
all pro Palestinian Liberation from a
terrorist group called Hamas apparently
everyone here but you what about from
the occupation are you Pro Palestinian
Liberation the occupation the the
blockade you want talk asking me
questions you're changing the topic the
one time I ask you a pro
murder I tell you what Emily I'll allow
that you you have asked her question she
can ask you go
on do you support Palestinian Liberation
from The Siege and blockade and the
occupation
that's factually incorrect how can I
talk to somebody who doesn't accept
basic United Nations partition plan
divided the land you waged the war you
does fact that a
17 if one Emily what I would say about
that one country if one country in this
case Israel is able to turn on and off
the tap of water and power and food for
the people of Gaza that is not a healthy
situation you can call it what you like
you can call it occupation you can call
it repression you can call it control
but that when they talk about freedom
for Palestine what they mean is we're
not reliant on Israel giving us water
food and energy so we can actually exist
correct and I'm happy you brought up
that point because they want their own
territory they want their own government
governmental body so when we pulled out
in 2005 2006 why couldn't they establish
that for themselves why are we giving
electricity and water to begin with and
my question is where is the hundreds of
millions of dollars of Aid being sent
directly to Palestine directly to Gaza
where is that money going but it was a a
rhetorical question question going
towards rocket $600 a rocket over $500
million I would raise a different point
actually I'll ra let me raise this Lise
more NBC News more than 80% of gaza's
population live in poverty poverty
according to the U we can all agree that
but Hamas has an Investment Portfolio of
real estate and other assets worth half
a billion dollars and an annual military
budget of $350 million a lot of
electricity one of the most disgusting
things about this entire period of time
has been watching Hamas leaders sitting
in Doha in Kata in their five-star
hotels telling poor Palestinian
civilians do not evacuate do not listen
to the IDF do not get out of these areas
that are being bombed and preventing
them from leaving that is a war are you
are you comfortable with that no that's
totally untrue and and I'm glad that you
brought that up because naftali also
spoke at it earlier when he talked about
how they gave the order to evacuate the
North and we all know that they gave
this evacuation order um to Gaza on
October 13 and what did they do when
people when they told them there's going
to be safe passage on this road for them
to evacuate they bombed that there has
been
zero
ver now you're conspirac as well okay
and there's a lot of things um that
zionists are doing that are that are
killing Palestinians like Biden saying
yesterday that the number of
Palestinians that have been killed may
not be true when we when the Palestinian
Ministry of Health had to come out and
release a PDF 231 pages of the names and
the ID numbers of every single I think
the point he was making is I I wouldn't
believe the word of a terrorist on
anything right you don't see them as
terrorists I do I want to talk about
Palestinian lives because you can't be
selective 40% of Hamas Rockets backfire
and kill innocent civilians the outrage
it is verified and I will I will provide
the source right after the show quote me
on it it is verified and secondly
Palestinian outrage about civilians is
very selective when the alleged Israeli
Army allegedly killed 500 Hospital
victims um when they found out it was
the Islamic Jihad where was the outrage
find out it was Islamic Jihad they did
it's
confirmed so you want to be a fact you
want to talk about one Hospital how many
hospitals how many Healthcare facilities
have been bombed by Israel I don't need
to focus I don't need to focus on one
particular
Hospital shelters we know this for a
fact are you bothered that they lied are
you bothered that the Hamas uh I'm bed
that your
I'm bed that your government that you
used to represent and that the US
government yes of course what kind of
question is that I'm devastated that
7,000 Palestinians are murdered I'm
beyond sad I'm devastated and I'm
devastated that I pay taxes to the
government that is doing that you can
leave you can go back to Gaza can I go
to Gaza can I go no I can't I was
actually denied entry to Palestine for
over for almost 10 years I was denied
entry when I was 20 years old because of
my let say something time out um I do
find these conversations completely
gripping I have to say because passions
are running very high on both sides I
think you both articulate your opinions
extremely well I think they resonate
with a lot of people the last interview
that you you both conducted with me has
had millions of views this one will do
again we should keep talking right one
of the things through this is to keep
talking in Northern Ireland where we had
appalling terrorism for a long time
eventually we got to a peace settlement
because people just kept talking and
Leadership came through that actually
wanted peace yeah journalism is very
important when it comes to this and
getting the word out there and talking
and unfortunately we know that the
family of the AL
jazer bureau chief was killed you know
after after they told qar to turn down
the volume on
Al I have to leave you there because I'm
going to talk to a very good friend of
Evan gersovitz who's of course the Wall
Street Journal journalist who's been
held captive in Russia so it's not just
in this situation happy birthday to it's
his birthday today
I'll be talking to to his good friend
after the break thank you all of you for
coming in much coming up President Biden
has promised the family detain
journalist Evan gershkovich the the US
will bring him home from Russia well
today on his 32nd birthday I'll be
speaking to one of his closest friends
and I've got some messages for him from
our beloved team arsenal we both support
the same football team I've got some
messages from Arsenal Legends for you
having on your birthday so we'll till
after the
break
[Music]
we're here good morning everybody hope
you're well thanks for joining us you're
watching the independent republic of
Mike gra right here on talk TV welcome
to Friday night with Nadine here on
prime time we like to speak to the
business people behind big moments good
evening I'm Piers Morgan uncensored in
New York City very impressive well
played I'm three days into the job what
have I done wrong and you face just
starred out at me me and you conquer
time who wins you do you know what I
love about tour today we do it all sunak
sella
scon are you actually speech writing for
richy sunak I'm so rich frankly uh I'm
going to take the side of boozed up
Brits against these pompous you mean
you're not going to support mayor Jose L
not stop panding to the nimes to the
naysayers and The National Society for
the preservation of the habitat of the
Lesser spotted M the problem lies in the
bureaucracy it's almost like those
highly paid Consultants don't really
know what they're
doing the first thing they teach you in
weather school is never confuse dog
walkers with Doggers Twitter you sons of
can you please reinstate my fit as a
butcher's dog there you go he's fit as a
butcher's dog all right but but he's now
middle class here the knock on effect is
far larger than just CO2 I nearly have
empathy when I'm speaking to them I know
know you're probably going to Boop me
after
sure kind to say I'm not I'm not a
Swifty critics i' say me included got
former PMS all over the joint saying
things the last few days we have indeed
yeah great first show you having fun oh
a ton of fun King peer and King C I
think is only room for one king man you
know what I'm saying just
[Music]
cuz welcome back to sensored live from
New York City Wall Street Journal
reporter Evan gershkovich celebrated his
32nd birthday today Behind Bars the
American was detained 211 days ago on
charges of Espionage which he The Wall
Street Journal and US Government
emphatically deny President Biden's
confirmed the US is in discussions with
Russia to secure the release of our
wrongfully detained colleague well today
on his birthday I've got some messages
which I'll leave to the end uh from some
Arsenal Legends uh because we both
support the same football team and
they're two great Legends and I think
he'll enjoy that on his birthday if they
ever get to be seen by him and I'm
joined Now by Evan's close friend Jeremy
but Jeremy great to see you um a lot of
focus today because it's Evan's birthday
do we know how he's doing do you have
any contact with him yeah first off
Piers thank you for the opportunity to
share Evan's story um we're trying to
beat the drum as loudly as we can to
bring him home to answer your questions
specifically uh we are able to send
letters uh he's able to read them and
send them back um however there is an
element of broken telephone is they have
to be translit into Russian and they're
read by Russian sensors to make sure
there's nothing in there um but we do
know that he's okay he's the type of
person that if anyone can handle the
situation he's in he's handling it with
a brave face it's it's a nightmare
situation that he's in um he's being
held obviously against his will on
trumped up charges at Espionage how do
you feel the campaign to get him out is
going look you know we trust that the
Biden Administration that Congress that
the state department is doing everything
they can to get him home um as his
friend it's not really my bearing uh to
to discuss the details and the specifics
of the strategy um however we do want to
make much more noise and we want to make
sure that given everything that's going
on in the world that this remains a
priority for the federal government that
we consistently keep the focus on Evan
to get them home as quickly as possible
that's our job what is clear from
journalist at the Wall Street Journal
it's it's a paper that's part of the
same company that this show is um what's
clear from all theour journalist who who
worked with Evan is he is an outstanding
journalist uh noted for his diligence
his hard work uh his Brilliance in the
field his knowledge um the idea that he
would be some spy is frankly for people
who know him ridiculous I mean you've
known him better than most yeah not only
is he an outstanding journalist Evan is
an outstanding friend um he's an
extroverts extrovert he has this ability
to draw you in when you're talking to
him it's like the rest of the world
doesn't matter and so what makes him
such a good friend is what makes him
such a good journalist and so I believe
uniquely able to tell the Russian story
and to communicate that to us at home um
you know I think he is absolutely in
prison on these like you said trumped up
charges uh Russia has presented really
no evidence for them and he's still even
awaiting trial and so this is just an
absolute Injustice and I feel for him
every single day and of course what he
should be doing is his job which is
reporting on Russia when they're still
engaged in this br brutal war in Ukraine
that's that's what he should be doing
right he's a great correspondent and I
think that's another tragedy of this is
that right at the moment that Russia's
at the center of his huge news story
he's unable to do his job I think for
him the toughest part is not that he's
in prison I think it's sitting on the
sidelines perhaps the biggest story of
his life knowing him he wants to be in
there he wants to be in the fire so to
speak um and I feel for him that he
doesn't have Thea the availability and
option to do that I know you're not an
Aral fan but I know you're an Aral fan
by proxy cuz used to haul you out of bed
to watch games at 6:00 a.m. maybe even
earlier sometimes I'm an Arsenal nutcase
and in fact I was at the Emirate stadium
in London arals ground when they had all
the banners uh for Evan yes uh which was
great to see and I remember tweeting
them and feeling very proud of the
Arsenal fans for supporting one of our
own in this dark moment for him but
we've actually on his birthday I've got
messages these names will mean nothing
to they'll mean an awful lot to Evan uh
they're from two of the Arsenal
invincibles it was a year in 2004 that
the team went unbeaten and it's from uh
Martin Keon Defender Ray paror
midfielder two great arsenal Legends
this is their messages for Evan happy
birthday Evan I know that times have
been difficult for you this season but
let's hope we can get you back in time
to see Arsenal pick up some silverware
at the end of the season Evan how are
you mate par here I just want to wish
you a very happy birthday mate I know
you've been struggling recently but uh
everybody's thinking of you uh and
hopefully I'll see you over the Emer so
you're a big Arsenal fan so thanks for
the support over the years mate uh if we
can hopefully win that premier league
title this year I'll see you at the EMS
and we can have a little bit of a party
to celebrate their Victory all the best
pal and happy birthday well that'd be
great wouldn't it to have a party to
celebrate Arsenal winning the Premier
League and Evans release and him to be
there to watch us do it Jeremy great to
see you thank you very much for coming
in and you can show your support for
Evan online by going to the website free
gurovich decom and on social media by
using the hashtags I stand with Evan and
free Evan on whatever platforms you use
happy birthday Evan keep fighting we'll
get you out of
[Music]
there
[Applause]
[Music]